let's me black and bollocks be honest
how many people are wearing this thing
in the thumbnails of their videos and/or
doing this well screw it I'm gonna do it
too I'm gonna take this thing to have an
imprint in my head right now
so Wonder Woman is directed by patty
Jenkins stars gal gadot this is a fourth
DC film in the DC Cinematic Universe I
believe it's the first live-action
Wonder Woman movie a lot is riding on
Wonder Woman for a lot of people in
Wonder Woman we meet Wonder Woman aka
Diana Prince he's an Amazon she loosens
the mascara which is an island of all
warrior women should they have some
authors lot of a warriors in a pilot
named Steve Trevor played by Chris Pine
crashes his plane on this island of all
women first man Diane has ever seen he's
a pilot from World War one and he tells
tale of this huge war that's happening
to Diane is like I'll go with you to
your world and help stop this war so now
we have our Wonder Woman movie really
the first half of this movie doesn't
have all the crazy kick-ass we you saw
in the trailer it really is her
climatized
to our world she enters our world she
enters London she really is a fish out
of water which allows for a lot of
comedy and I really feel that they got
the comedy right in this movement kind
of reminded me is in the vein of
Crocodile Dundee how this person from
this other land comes to what we know as
normal and it is completely abnormal to
them by normal I mean it takes place in
World War one so not a lot of people
living today know that world as normal
but there is a lot in that world that we
still do know and relate to in our world
but Diana is completely bafflingly weird
and talking about the comedy Chris Pine
really adds a lot to that Chris Pine was
great in this movie he's just the
perfect person to cast you saw that in
the trailer where she was like I was
conceived by Zeus and he's like well
that's me that timing that he has
completely plays in this movie in plays
wow I feel like Chris Pine even though
he's been james t kirk is a completely
underrated talent with great timing and
delivery a gal gadot just wonder woman
credit where credit's due
when i heard she was a Wonder Woman I
was like they got a model to be Wonder
Woman okay what she put in the time
she's all downes she's got biceps like
she kicked my ass let's face it she
could have kicked my ass when she was G
before she worked out for Wonder Woman
but ask for Wonder Woman she completely
played well didn't play perfectly like
for example Chris Pine you look at him
there are very few people I could pick
to play Steve Trevor as well as Chris
Pine did / what they were going for I
feel like there are a few women out
there who could have played Wonder Woman
couple of the moments where she has to
bring out the
she brings out the emotion doesn't stick
all of the landing she's being honest
however she did play well I didn't walk
out of the movie going well she ruined
it I thought she was good but she really
does shine in the action sequences I
don't know where the stunt person placed
into this the Wonder Woman is kicking
ashore like yeah this is pretty exotic
that scene where she goes out in the
battlefield she's just taken all the
fire with her shield that scene is as
cool as you want it to be that happens
about halfway through the movie when
that scene happens on the movie moves
just like alright the fish-out-of-water
thing the funnies the camaraderie it's
gone time to move forward with the
mission and it is some exciting stuff
when the slow-mo starts happy there's a
lot of slow-mo and the action sequences
at first she's like yeah like matrix
style then later on you're like they use
a lot of slow-mo for these action
sequences so really when an action
sequence is going down and there's no
slow-mo and it's just moving really fast
to me that's more exciting but we'll
really lock me into this movie was the
humanity that Wonder Woman shows and
really that is credit for patty Jenkins
the director and gal gadot the actors
yeah she's super and she can go toe to
toe with Superman any day but in the end
she is a human being she feels pain she
feels lost she feels pressure and when
she lets it all out she can rage clear a
room the movie although it has solid
kick-ass hurry when it goes down is not
an action centric movie it's actually a
very personal story about Diana it's a
coming-of-age story she doesn't really
know all of her powers so she's learning
it as she goes along so they make
Diana's strong in this movie without
browbeating EULA it's not like oh man
bad Wonder Woman good because it's not
really what it should be Wonder Woman is
a strong character because she exhibits
strength not because the men around her
exhibit weakness I thought that was a
really important thing there are a
couple of great moments of heart there
is a scene where Steve Trevor and Diana
are talking about humanity it is
probably my favorite scene in the movie
she's such good dialogue I'm not gonna
tell you what it just really hit me guys
in the end I completely enjoyed Wonder
Woman there are some problems with
pacing in the first part of the movie it
is another big end fight that happens DC
movies men they love their big n fights
I felt like by the end of the ending it
came across it's a little cheap but the
movie as a whole has a lot of good
payoff
there is a lot of pressure on this movie
for a lot of people there are people who
want wonder woman to represent strong
women I totally get that there are
people who want Wonder Woman to save the
DC Cinematic Universe for them I totally
get that and there are some people who
just want to enjoy a good movie I
totally get that and I think if you're
any of those people you'll walk out a
Wonder Woman
like yeah it paid off Wonder Woman was
fun it was exciting Chris Pine was great
I think the director patty Jenkins
really crushed I think they really
utilized the fact that Wonder Woman
takes place so far before the Justice
League and all that stuff's going down
you had the freedom to just break off
and be its own movie if you haven't seen
any movies in the DC Cinematic Universe
you could watch Wonder Woman and not be
lost there's one scene at the beginning
that kind of ties it in a little bit but
you don't need it though I feel like I
kind of hamstrung myself on this one
with the Suicide Squad which you
remember my rating for Suicide Squad yep
there it is yeah people on the internet
loved their writings and this is better
than Suicide Squad so I will say Wonder
Woman is worth watching and worth buying
on blu-ray alright guys so Wonder Woman
have you seen it what did you think
about it or what are your hopes for
Wonder Woman what do you want to see
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always if you like what you
seen here and you wanna see more click
right here to see more
[Music]